as long as you're gonna have uh the
right people
smart passionate driven
with the right set of values
they can build the companies that gonna
define the future
and there's uh there's
the good ideas never end uh there's
enough ideas for everyone it's an and
there's not passion for everyone
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance
hello stanford leap and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
going to have a lot of fun talking about
venture capital from one of the most
respected investors in israel in grove
ventures laton levkovitz general partner
at grow ventures
lotan has been an early stage technology
investor since 2012 with a special
interest in iot digital health trust and
safety cloud infrastructure and
enterprise i.t
he currently serves on the boards of
active fans 3d signals lumigo rapid api
beyond mines and navina rotan is also
the founder of the israeli industrial
iot forum and the ii4 conference prior
to joining grove ventures lautan was a
strategic consultant at tasc an
international management consultancy
firm where he focused on the
telecommunications sector lautan served
as a commander and an elite israeli air
force intelligence unit where he was
honored with an award of excellence he
holds a bachelor of law degree lb and a
bachelor of business administration
degree a ba from the hebrew university
in jerusalem
latan lefkovitz welcome to 20 minute
leaders i'm so honored and excited to
have you here how are you
i'm good hi michael thank you for having
me
i'm so excited we're gonna have such a
good time in these 20 minutes this is
one of those episodes where i'm so upset
that i only called this show 20 minute
leaders and not like 40 minute leaders
but we'll make do with what we can latan
you're responsible for some of the most
exciting investments that i know of here
in the israel ecosystem you're
either a board member or board observer
of some fantastic companies many of them
are great friends of mine you're working
with really great friends of mine and
and your journey is is so fascinating
and your your perception of what's
happening in the vc
scene as a whole and specifically in the
israel ecosystem is just fascinating
through multiple publications of your
work on on the israeli media and so i'm
excited to pick your brain in these 20
minutes before we get to all of the vc
stuff and the hardcore tech stuff take
me back a little bit who is lautan how
do you end up in venture capital
well um the real story it was pure luck
and coincidence i started as a very
geeky kid with my computer like i think
many of the people now in the uh tech
ecosystem back then and we didn't know
yet that uh to be
actually a cool thing
uh i started my very first job was it
was when i was 15 i never stopped
working since then uh but it wasn't a cd
store back in the 90s the end of the 90s
music was my thing besides computers and
music was my passion and for three years
all across my high school years i sold
cds
and so really actually it was a very
good deal for them because all the money
i earned i actually spent on music
uh but it means that i never took like
allowance for my parents since i was 15.
um and then i got into the israeli air
force intelligence i was a transplant
inside 8200
um but actually um i don't know if you
want if you give it an 8200 i know if
you saw like the air force guys
they like them but kind of like not like
them in the same time yes and it really
opened my my brain because um i didn't
like my school years that much it was
not that intrigued but then i saw a way
to um do whatever i wanted in a way it
was like a very good canvas and we
worked our asses off and we saw that we
were creating some value and that was
great
um and then i think that was a very
transformational moment because i knew
that
if i really work hard and have passion i
can actually do something
um and since then
because that's that's not a trivial
understanding to have what made you
really understand that if you're
passionate about something then you
don't have to go the traditional route
you can you can build something of your
own or you can build your own path
so i was very fortunate
to be ended up in a small unit inside of
like a small air force inside a very big
intelligence base of 8200 guys uh and we
were like a small startup in a way that
um
it was only up to us
to create value for our customers which
was like the air force
in that sense and it was very
entrepreneurial because we really have
to do whatever we can they pull all the
strings try to maneuver all the big
system to get what we need and then we
had some very interesting events during
my service years we built some systems
we generated some very good intelligence
and it was all due to our uh deter uh
being very determined
and
as a very young kid you know it was 18
19 20 years old we actually made the
debt
and
that was like a very self-fulfilling and
phenomenal experience
um
and and i think that does when making
the in the regular school day i was
quite
bored or didn't feel like fit in
and there i really felt like at home
and i think i took that uh that feeling
and that's really
supports me all across the years and i
usually been a contrarian in everything
i did it was like a bit of a misfit in
many places and so i really tried hard
like uh should i do this would i do that
like after being like an air force
intelligence like okay uh [__]
technology is not for me let's do
something else so i went to law school
it was not for me i tried also business
school it was not for me i worked in
like i didn't be a bartender i worked in
israeli knesset i tried everything and i
i didn't
so i went to i did consulting uh so i'd
been in the era of the telecom where
like telecom moved from sorry for like
going like uh deep down memory lane but
uh when telecom went from the second
generation to the third generation
digitalization what started happening
like media changed itself iphone was
there so i went to technology but from
now from the business side
it was fascinating and i thought that
maybe okay maybe that's going to be my
life
and i think the most transformational
event was when um i met a legend i met
someone i really admired this guy was
name was doug moran and it was like from
people that grew up in the 90s like me
he was like like meeting steve jobs
and uh and then
i kind of knew someone that knew someone
that knew someone that knew him
and we had a good chemistry and he said
you know what do you want to work for me
so i like pause for like 20 seconds just
so we won't see how excited i am
of course yes yes yes yes i'm gonna do
whatever
you're gonna tell me and and i think
being like very like tightly coupled
with dove in in the last decade i think
really
got me i think and then and and then
like we worked together we invested his
money across like different startups it
was a different time different model and
then we saw
that we believed that there was a gap in
the israeli vca ecosystem
and i told him like douglas maybe we
should start a vc fund and he started
from no way i'm going to be a venture
capitalist to uh it took me a year to
get into okay let's do it and then he
made me his partner and this is how we
started grove
and this is how i became a venture
capitalist your question sorry for the
very long answer but so it was not like
a linear way of yeah i knew forever like
since i was born i'm being gonna be a
venture capitalist i guess i i didn't
know what i'm gonna do so i had to learn
different stuff i had to look at reality
from different angles and that's got me
to where i am today
what is the lens that
over the past decade you've sort of
brought for yourself as you're
approaching the investment world what is
it what does it really mean to be eventu
a venture capitalist for you obviously
right now grove is one of the most
prominent uh venture capital funds in
israel but what does it mean to you
personally as an investor with what
lenses do you come into this role
okay so first of all um from day one
what i realized that i'm not the most
experienced
i'm not the smartest not the luckiest so
only thing i can be is to be different
so i thought if i'm gonna have a belief
about the reality about the future which
is a bit different than others
then maybe i can be successful if i'm
right
so i think being venture capitalist and
especially what we try to do in early
stage to be like the first very good
partners of these founders
is about um having your belief about the
future and helping entrepreneurs try to
get there and we had um and so for me
being a good venture capitalist is
getting the best teams you can you can
find and try to help them to remove
obstacles and create that reality to
create the future
right and so tell me a little bit about
you know how you've seen the israeli
ecosystem transform and and where we're
at today what is this inflection point
where near the end of 2021 it's been a
roller coaster of a few years things
have dramatically changed you've written
quite extensively about this from your
perspective but what what are some of
the bigger things that you've seen
transform and where are we at today
so when we started grow uh we believe
that we saw the israeli ecosystem with
much less money less investors and we
saw the the same things coming over and
over and over again
and we thought maybe uh we can
bring like new things to the table we
started we saw that the world is going
through a digital transformation we felt
like that they're going to be like a
major innovation and change of paradigm
in like areas around what's happening in
the edge and iot and the physical like
where the physical world actually meet
innovation in tech we saw that the
infrastructure the cloud either like in
the hardware side or software side new
types of microservices api economy is
coming and changing the whole way the
infrastructure is actually being built
and we saw that everything around like
data analytics is coming like uh whether
it's not going to be like ai or
different buzzwords like deep learning
machine learning uh back then this was
like big data right
um
and you said that combination of all
these three actually gonna transform a
lot of the fundamentals of our world
where like most of the gdp is uh
manufacturing supply chain healthcare et
cetera et cetera most of the money of
the economy is there but not out of the
innovation actually been coupled with
these industries so this is what growth
believed from day one that we want to be
part of the digital transfer information
of these industries
or really investing in the
infrastructure that going to enable this
transformation
and we when we started you know we
talked about for example like
semiconductors
um investors that we talked with it said
like guys you know that 90s have ended
semiconductors in the past uh but what
we see now your question about 2021
it's sexy again it's coming back right
you see that a lot of the areas that we
believe that we wanted to be pioneering
in the markets like what's happening
when technology emit uh manufacturing
industry 4.0
when we started people saying like you
know that's not a good buyer that the
market dynamics is not going to enable
startup to exist and now it's booming
it's everywhere especially after coving
we saw what's happening in healthcare
that the system was
mainly the u.s system was structured in
a way that really prevented innovation
to come and and now digital health is
everywhere bioinformatics is changing
out of the things
um
um we have a very strong belief that
developers are not only users they're
actually buyers what's happening just
like business to developers kind of
model like how software infrastructure
are going to happen and all these things
we're seeing now
amazing and huge companies actually
selling to developers not only built by
developers explore developers and all
these like very big changes that are
happening in front of our eyes
and to to our belief not now in israel
we if israel used to have like one
not not one tree pony but like it was
everything around like um telecom
back in the days or everything around
our cyber we see different verticals and
different opportunities for founders to
build very very good companies that
gonna answer the biggest needs of the
world
now what do you have to do as an
investor because
unlike a lot of a lot of traditional
investors in venture capital you're
looking at the industry 4.0 you're
looking at technologies that can
literally transform the way that the
world operates on a very fundamental
level right
what do you have to do then as an
investor to either prepare yourself or
educate yourself to be able to have
those strong convictions of supporting
the right teams to go about this mission
because these are teams that you know
they're going all out they're
you know they have the potential to
literally make it to make a huge dent in
the in either complicated supply chains
or in the really fundamental way that
we're interacting in our daily lives
i think it's a lot depends like being
having a prepared mind is reading a lot
meeting other people and building your
network within these industries
um
a lot of our my uh our time my time is
dedicated to
to build our network and relationships
within these target markets it really
enables us that when we meet like a very
young team of entrepreneurs and actually
introducing them into the market and
helping them to knock on these doors and
be part of this relationship and these
ideation phases and i think it gets us
to be sometimes more brave
early on
um i'll give you an example like um
uh
we i invested in a company called active
fence active fence is attacking the
world of like trust and safety is the
world that we all familiar with from
like the news and the headlines um
what's happening with uh
sorry for now uh remembering all the
positiveness but uh pedophiles
terrorists uh misinformation uh all
these like very nasty stuff someone have
to stop it and this whole new world is
called like trust and safety when i met
acting fans they had like
almost nothing happening and they had
this idea of how the future gonna emerge
actually we can't stop it it's actually
it's a problem like someone some people
actually care about it not only the
media and regulators
and we had to go and to find these like
very early customers and talk with them
and understand that this is actually
going to be the future
so really went as part of the due
diligence and gathered the biggest like
big tech companies got them to the table
and validated their need and actually
eventually these are became like very
fundamental customers for for the
company so it's about like really being
able to roll up your sleeves and going
to work
i had to take a plane to london at that
case because these guys didn't
weren't ready to take an official
meeting so i had to meet i have i had a
friend in that company and he got me
like this unofficial meeting in a cafe
outside of their office and they really
explained to me how they look at this
world
unbelievable and and so where are we
headed now you know as an industry
whether it's you know the the way that
entrepreneurs are approaching the world
especially from the israeli perspective
obviously we're talking from startup
nation to scale-up nation also from a
venture capital perspective what do you
think we can expect in the next few
years and even what what can i as a
young venture capitalist you know start
thinking about as i'm considering where
we're headed
i think that's as long in here in israel
or even in a brother like tech world as
long as you're going to have uh the
right people
smart passionate driven
with the right set of values
they can build the companies that gonna
define the future
and there's uh there's
the good ideas never end uh there's
enough ideas for everyone it's an and
there's not passion for everyone and as
long as they're going to build the
infrastructure and the culture for this
like next wave of huge companies they're
going to define the future we're good
so i think uh i'm by the way i'm a young
venture capitalist myself like nine
years is nothing in that industry right
uh it's about uh knowing
how to be a bit different and uh like
staying a bit like once uh set remote
from the herd
and then try to actually
invest in new markets and new
opportunities and new needs
and i think this is where the next
transformational companies and the
category defining companies going to be
at
how does that connect to latin the
misfit from before
i think all of my companies um active
fans is killing it in trust and safety
really just now it's like a hundred
million dollar around two years three
and a half years after establishment and
they're a very very different set of
company if you're gonna look at the
other startup playbook they're different
uh look at what happened like in rapid
api where were the first investors how
what they did in the api market even
though when we invested was 16 and a
half years old that's like
different everybody looked at me like
other investors said like come on it's
not it's not like a child's play and it
though is one of the best founders i met
he's brilliant he's killing it and
really changing his industry look at
like the guys on in lumigo they're
really building a different company the
guys in the veena they they came out of
8200 they knew everything about
multi-modal ai and nothing about the
world and what's their they're killing
it in primary care market they finally
go to market it's like provider first if
you're like familiar with the healthcare
that's very very very different and they
were brave and we said if you're gonna
be different
we might might like fail with our faces
like in the puddle of mud and if we
succeed it's gonna be huge so
for me trying to be different
um i think having this like misfit uh
a background as an advantage that
disadvantage it's really direct the way
i'm being as a venture capitalist and
very very lucky i'm surrounded by 15
amazing people in grove we created the
whole platform to help our our companies
we i'm having amazing partners
not each one in his own field is a
legend really i'm so lucky to be
surrounded by them and they helping me
and then we help each other to get like
more confidence to be brave each one in
its own direction
i love it and obviously you know a lot
of people talk about you know the
relationship between venture capitalists
and and the entrepreneurs and especially
as you're sitting you know as a
representative on the board of a lot of
these companies you know you're the
representation of this misfit and and
the encouragement of being different
being bold and brave and going against
the grain and being i i can only imagine
how how much you know mental and
emotional support beyond the
intellectual support that that provides
to the to the founders which i think is
just incredible if you look at your day
to day right now
where do you draw the inspiration
obviously you work so hard you're
constantly looking at companies you're
supporting the portfolio companies what
gets you up in the morning every day
what what is it about your role right
now that really excites you
when he started growing we defined like
core two core values
and that's weird like y vc should have
values like companies have values funds
usually don't have values but if you
have to it's the first one is like
people first
and to create value
so it's not necessarily financial value
it's really value to the world and
that's what gets me up in the morning
the people around me it's my partners
which i love and the people in our in
our in our team really meeting these
people every morning gets me out from
bed and the people around me like the
founders
and and their teams that's really what
gets me up and to create value it's not
the financial values leaving the world a
bit better than how i found it
i love it and and i think that goes back
to the conversation we had just before
starting this recording which which i
love this shared valley that we have and
if i were to ask your founders or dove
or or anybody else that surrounds you
what are some words that define who
lotan is
what would be some of those words
think is um very
driven like relentless i can i i work
hard
um
um i think that um
i think that's thoughtful like i always
like overthink things um
i spend a lot of my time reading and
learning and not sleeping out at night
but really trying to think like what's
happening in the world outside of my
like my comfort zone what's going to be
the next step and the next next step
and i think uh being positive and happy
like i think i i try i i'm very lucky
about it like my chemistry in the brain
probably like set up in the right way uh
this is like something i got from my
grandparents that didn't have like an
easy life but being like happy
being positive that will get you off
through all the difficulties of life and
all this like roller coaster of venture
capital over startups so and we are very
lucky to be living in that time of
humanity like um and always like look at
the positive side of everything
thank you very very much
and thank you for sharing it from your
journey and for the inspiring 20 minutes
it was wonderful and stay safe and stay
healthy
[Music]
you